اذا كنت من هواه الايفون او الايباد سيصبح
بامكانك للمره الاولى تنزيل تطبيقات من
خارج الاب ستور ليست سعيده على الاطلاق
الارغمت على ذلك بموجب متطلبات جديده
صارمه في الاتحاد الاوروبي سيبدا تطبيقها
عام 2024 اهميته هذا التغيير ليست فقط في
توسيع الخيارات المتاحه بل في تجنب قيود
ابل وعموله الثلاثين في المئه التي تفرضها
على كل الخدمات المباعه عبر التطبيقات
القواعد الاوروبيه اتت بعد سنوات طويله من
شكاوي مطوري التطبيقاتهم لابل وجوجل
الاحتكاريه كلنا نذكر الحرب القانونيه
التي دارت بين شركه ابل وقيام الاخيرتي
لازاله لعبه فورت نايت من مجالها
لكن في النهايه قرر القضاء الامريكي انا
عاقل لم تنتهي قوانين مكافحه الاحتكار
الفيدراليه القواعد الاوروبيه الجديده
ستطبق على الشركات التكنولوجيا التي تقدر
قيمتها السوقيه بما لا يقل عن 80 مليار
دولار ولا يقل عدد مستخدميها عن 45 مليون
استخدم شهريا في الاتحاد الاوروبي شركه
ابل تتذرع بان التحميل الجانبي يمكن ان
يتسبب في تحميل تطبيقات غير امنه على
اجهزه المستهلكين للحمايه من هذه
التطبيقات غير الامنه وناقش ابل فرده
متطلبات امنيه وقد تفرض عمليه التحقق
المسبق على هذه التطبيقات مع رسوم شبيهه
بالرسوم التي تفرضها على تطبيقات الاب
ستور في كل الاحوال من المؤكد ان قاعده
الارادات ستتاثر بالقواعد الاوروبيه
الجديده والاخطر ان الاتحاد الاوروبي حدد
بغرامه تصل الى 20% من الاردادات الثانويه
العالميه للشركه اذا انتهاكت القانون
مرارا وتكرارا فقط لتاخذ الفكره شركه ابل
حققت ارادات عالميه لنحو اربع مئه مليون
دولار في السنه الماليه 2022 يعني ان
الغرامه لا يمكن ان تصل الى 80 مليار دول
على الرغم من ذلك قابل قادره على استيعاب
التاثير المالي حيث يشكل اب ستور سته في
المئه من اجمالي اردادات الشركه فقط
مساهمه اوروبا في ذلك اقل من اثنين في
المئه».\